earlier today Sajid Javid said the
mindset of the government needs to
change when trying to tackle violent
crimes such as knife crime or one person
trying to raise more awareness of the
issue is the award-winning grime artist
governor bee who delivers anti-crime
messages and his gospel lyrics and I'm
pleased to say that he joins us now in
the studio great to have you here what
do you think of what Sajid Javid said
today I thought it was long overdue
because I've always believed that the
mentality of people committing crime and
being involved in serious youth violence
is something that is a disease when you
wake up and you think that you know I've
been conditioned into a way of thinking
that I want to take someone else's life
or another person I think it needs to be
approached as a disease so what the Home
Secretary is saying about a public
health approach and to see what the
community can do collectively to prevent
opportunities for young people to be
involved in crime I think is is a great
tactic what can communities do I mean
you know we talked about more funding we
talk about more leisure activities
things to divert young people who seem
to have a lot of time on their hands
into productive things and I mean is
that the answer or is it more bobbies on
the beach what something well my mom's
from Ghana and she used to say this
Ghanaian saying that it takes a village
to raise a child and I think that's
everyone in a community coming together
and asking what can I do to personally
help this situation for me it went as
far as my primary school teacher sitting
me down when I was naughty and saying
you know what you're really good at
writing stories I would love for you to
try a bit harder in English she made me
believe in myself and that maybe change
the trajectory of my life so it's from
the police to the parents and the
communities to youth services every
single person asking what is in my hands
and what can I do to help this situation
but you know we're not in a village in
Ghana and people don't necessarily feel
that there is much of a community in
some parts of London at least I mean
what you know are you suggesting that
people you know is it as simple as
getting to know your neighbors better
thank you it could be as simple as
getting to know your neighbors better I
feel like you
it's quite stereotypical because I live
in Greenwich South East London and I
feel like I'm part of a community I've
got friends in East London town town all
over London it's all that they're parts
of a community for that sometimes when
people look at young people they feel
fear or they feel like a lack of
connection but sometimes it's as easy as
saying you know what I see you putting
your arm around someone and saying
you're the same as me we're individuals
and we can work together to move forward
in life a big thing that changed for me
was I used to wake up every single day
and just drift through life not really
know why I was here but through faith
and through different people speaking
into my life I found that that I
actually have a purpose and I have
something to give to the world I feel
like if we encourage young people we let
them know that no they're not just here
to make up the numbers or be a name on a
register but actually they can give
something to the world it gives them
something to wake up for and a goal to
achieve you talked about your music
there I mean that there has been a lot
of aspersions cast towards certain types
of music including Brian music to say
that this is partly fueled some of the
problems with knife crime what are you
doing differently how are you changing
that message is getting across just
showing the other side of the coin it
frustrates me that the view of the music
whether it's rap if what Brian is that
it just promotes violence misogyny drug
abuse antisocial behavior that's not my
truth I know various artists that are
solely promoting positive messages free
music messages of love as peace of hope
and I feel like if some of the decision
makers and the gatekeepers were to shine
more of a light on the artists doing
that kind of stuff then maybe you would
see a change in the narrative of course
music doesn't it might encourage
violence but it's not the root cause I
feel like it's a lot deeper than that
can it stop violence do you think I feel
like it's a bunch of different
approaches not solely music but everyone
then what they can to come together to
fight this issue it can definitely help
prevent it for a messaging but it's not
the sole solution for stopping
as the Home Secretary said it's a
collective approach okay well very good
to meet you governor we thank you very
much for coming in